you know friends and family of Kelly
Clarkson are still shocked about the
news that she and her husband Brandon
Blackstock are getting a divorce but if
you think this is going to get ugly
think again my husband Sam there he he
makes me feel so sexy like you know I
was making fun of him like why are you
touching my behind in public like why
you like I'm an interview and he likes
quit you know he'll like goose me or
something that's so quick and I'm like
what do you know but I'm like I really
like it
Kelly always gushed about her husband of
nearly seven years but our source says
they had been having problems for
several months and were making a
conscious effort to work things out so
were there Clues the relationship was in
trouble we're very different my husband
and I and we definitely try and make
each other better and call each other
out when we do things
I mean we're different we work on that
you know because we're two different
worlds coming together
in 2013 the busy musician married her
busy manager then came three albums The
Voice the Kelly Clarkson show and her
Vegas residency it is but I'm kind of
that person oh and don't forget raising
two young kids by the end of the day I
am in bed with my toddlers like this cut
to 20/20 our source says they both hope
quarantine in Montana would help them
work things out but constant time
together seemed to make an already
challenging situation worse
Brandon's the EP of her talk show and
became much more my husband is now a
lighting technician and audio-visual
technician ease of director and he's
also playing cowboy on our ranch so know
he's got his hands full we both
definitely have our hands full 100% this
none of this would be happening without
my partner in crime a source close to
production on the Kelly Clarkson show
tells et many staffers were stunned over
her divorce filing the show remains in
production no word Brandon will stay on
his ep
besides working non-stop another major
issue having more kids brandon has two
teens from a previous marriage back in
2016 Kelly told us this after having
river in Remington oh no I was mid
pregnancy with Remy and I made my
husband cook kids he I didn't have to
force him he was running to the doctor
like we both were like no well Kelly's
had a change of heart
I still want another child and my
husband is like no we have for our
source tells us a few weeks ago Kelly
started the divorce process realizing
divorce was her only option but she and
Brandon haven't cut each other off they
are still talking both heartbroken but
their plan is to put the kids first
Kelly's asked for joint custody of River
and Remy enforcement of their prenup and
no spousal support for Brandon you've
got to be intimate with each other like
regularly like you got to last year the
38 year old told us intimacy was key to
their marriage that's difficult since
the entire family was living in a
one-room cabin you've got to make time
for date nights you've got a beat you've
got to have that intimacy that
one-on-one like often because even when
Breen and I start like getting on each
other's nerves like you know then we
have that night and we're like all right
I love you like yeah
[Music]